in this video you're going to learn how
to solve trig equations and we're going
to go through six examples together
we're going to talk about how to find
the general solution as well as just
from 0 to 2 pi so let's dive into these
six examples we're going to be using the
unit circle here so if you haven't
memorized it it's helpful to know this
unit circle or have one handy let's take
a look at the first example the first
example 2 cosine x minus 1 equals zero
you can think about this just like you
would think about solving a regular
algebra equation but instead of getting
the X by itself think about isolating
that particular trig function in this
case cosine how can you get the cosine X
by itself well thinking about working
from the outside in what I would do is I
would add 1 to both sides
so now we're left with 2 cosine x equals
1 and then I would divide both sides by
2 to get that cosine by itself and so
now we're left with cosine of x is equal
to one half so you go to your unit
circle and you'd say where is cosine
equal to one-half remember on the unit
circle the cosine corresponds to the x
coordinate the sine refers or
corresponds to the y coordinate and the
tangent is the Y divided by the X so in
this case where does the cosine equal
one-half that's where the x coordinate
is one half that's going to be right
here at pi over 3 and at 5 pi over 3.
now sometimes when I'm doing these
problems I like to just draw a little
sketch for myself and I'd say okay
here's pi over 3.
and here's 5 pi over 3 and if we were
just going once around this unit circle
if the instruction just said okay you
know solve this equation from 0 to 2 pi
your answers would just be pi over 3 and
5 pi over 3. but if you're here at pi
over 3 and you were to go all the way
around the unit circle again
you would end up in the same spot and
the cosine that x coordinate would still
be one half so what we can do is we can
add
multiples of 2 pi now your teacher might
say 2 pi K or 2 pi n as long as n is an
integer you're adding a full Revolution
and you're gonna end up at the same spot
now if n was a negative one you'd be
going the other direction you would
still end up at the same spot same thing
with 5 pi over 3 you could add multiples
of 2 pi n and so that's going to be
your general solution let's take a look
at another example
okay for example number two we've got 6
sine squared x minus 3 equals zero so
again working from the outside in
towards this sine function we want to
isolate that let's go ahead and add 3 to
both sides of the equation
so that gives us 6 sine squared x is
equal to 3. Let's divide both sides by
six
and so now we have sine squared x is
equal to one half of reduce the fraction
and because it's a sine squared of X
let's take the square root of both sides
remember when you take the square root
of both sides of an equation you get two
answers plus or minus the square root of
one is one the square root of 2 is just
square root of two and then let's go
ahead and rationalize this by
multiplying the numerator and
denominator by the square root of 2. so
that gives us 1 times square root of 2
is square root of 2 square root of 2
times square root of 2 is square root of
4 which is just 2. and so now we're
looking at where does the sine of x
equal to plus or minus the square root
two over two remember the sign on the
unit circle corresponds to the y
coordinate so we're saying where is the
y coordinate equal to square root 2 over
2 or negative square root 2 over 2.
looks like it's going to be at four
locations here and let's just go ahead
and draw a sketch so that's going to be
at pi over 4
3 pi over 4 5 pi over 4 and 7 pi over 4.
and if the instructions just say you
know what are the solutions between 0
and 2 pi once around that unit circle
you would just list those those angles
pi over 4
3 pi over 4
5 pi over 4 and 7 pi over 4. now if we
want to write it as a general solution
what you might notice here is that to go
from pi over 4 to 3 pi over 4 we're
adding
pi over 2 or 90 degrees and same thing
here we're adding another 90 degrees
another 90 degrees another 90 degrees so
what you can do since you just keep
adding 90 each time or pi over 2 you can
say that our angle X is equal to pi over
plus pi over 2 N where n is an integer
again you're just adding 90 to get to
the next point on the unit circle next
Point next Point add infinitum forever
so this would be your general solution
let's take a look at another example
okay for example number three now we
have 2 cosine squared x minus cosine x
minus 1 equals zero so how would we
solve this one
well you can see this is like a
trinomial like three terms and we have a
quadratic term this cosine squared term
and like a linear term to the first
degree cosine
so what you could think about is the
factoring this into two binomials you
could even think of this as like imagine
if this was 2x squared minus x minus 1
how would you factor that
well in this case we can see that 2x
times 1X gives us the 2x squared and a
negative 1 and a positive one that
multiplies to negative 1 and then the
inside and the outside 1X and negative
2x adds up to the middle term
but really we're dealing with cosine so
let me replace X here with cosine X so
this is going to be 2 cosine X plus one
times cosine x minus 1 is equal to zero
now that we have it factored we can set
each factor each group equal to zero and
solve so let's go ahead and do that so
we have two
cosine X plus one equals 0.
and cosine x minus 1 equals zero here if
we add 1 to both sides
we can see that cosine X is equal to 1
over here if we subtract one from both
sides
and divide by 2
we can see cosine is equal to negative
one half so going to our unit circle now
let's start with this one where does
cosine equal one well cosine is the x
coordinate and it's going to be one just
right here at zero so let's draw a
sketch we'll say basically it's going to
be right here
okay at zero
or where does cosine equal negative
one-half that's where again where the x
coordinates negative one-half that's
going to be here at 2 pi over three
or here at 4 pi over three
and that's it now what's interesting if
we were just saying what's the solution
from zero to two Pi we would just list
these angles 0 2 pi over three and four
pi over 3. but if we want a general
solution what you might notice here is
that these are evenly spaced right so
this is actually two pi over 3 another 2
pi over three another two pi over 3
takes us back to 6 pi over 3 which is 2
pi or zero so we can write this as a
general solution in a more condensed Way
by saying that X is equal to 2 pi over
three
times n where n is an element of the set
of integers okay that's what the Z here
represents so basically if n is 0 you're
going to be right had zero if n is one
you're at two pi over three if n is 2
you're at 4 pi over 3 and if n is three
you're back to 2 pi so you're kind of
starting over again so this is like a
condensed way of writing our general
solution let's take a look at another
example okay for example number four now
we have square root of 3 times cotangent
of 3x equals one now this is what we
call a multiple angle type and I'm
trying to show you a variety of
different problems in this video like
we've did a factoring one and we just
did some more standard type problems and
now this is a multiple angle one so here
again what we're going to do is we're
going to try to isolate this cotangent
function by itself so I'm going to start
by dividing both sides by square root of
3.
and then now we have cotangent of the
quantity 3x is equal to and I'm just
going to rationalize this by multiplying
the numerator and denominator by square
root of 3. so this comes out to square
root of 3 over square root of 9 which is
just 3.
so now what we're going to do is we're
going to treat this angle like a group
or a chunk we're going to say cotangent
of what angle equals root 3 over 3. now
cotangent is the x coordinate divided by
the y coordinate tangent is y divided by
X cotangent is the reciprocal it's X
over Y and you can see that's going to
occur over here at pi over 3
and
4 pi over 3. now you might be saying
Mario how did you know that well see
cotangent which is one half
divided by root three over two so we're
just doing the X over The Y when you
divide by a fraction it's like
multiplying by the reciprocal right so
the twos are going to cancel and then we
have 1 over root 3 which is what we
started with right here
also over here in the third quadrant you
can see the X and the Y are the same and
they're also the same sign they're both
negative so a negative divided by
negative will also give you a positive
root 3 over 3. so if I was to draw a
sketch here I'd see that on my unit
circle here at pi over 3
and 5 Sorry 4 pi over 3. notice how
these are across from each other they're
like a diameter they're like a 180
degrees apart or you could say Pi
radians apart
so if I was to write a general solution
here we actually solve for 3x so what we
have is 3x is equal to pi over 3 plus
we're adding 180 degrees or Pi radians
times n so if you keep adding Pi you're
here another Pi or here another Pi so
you keep going halfway around that unit
circle and you're ending up at one of
these two points where cotangent is
equal to root three over three but see
the thing is we don't want 3x we just
want One X so let's go ahead and divide
everything by three left and right sides
of the equation to keep this balanced
and that's going to give us x equals pi
over nine
plus pi over 3n now this is our general
solution where n is an integer but if
the instruction set I you know you just
want the answers from 0 to 2 pi what I
would do is I'd start by putting in
values for n now pi over 3 is like
3 pi over 9. okay so what we could do is
we could say we want n is 0
we have pi over 9. when n is 1
that's going to be pi over 9 plus 3 pi
over 9 which is 4 pi over 9.
when n is 2 that's 6 pi over 9 plus 1 pi
over 9 is 7 pi over 9 when n is 3 that's
9 pi over 9 plus 1 pi over 9 is 10 pi
over 9. you can see we keep adding 3 to
the numerator here so if I follow that
pattern 13 pi over 9
16 pi over 9
. 19 pi over 9 you can see 19 pi over 9
is actually more than 2 pi so that's not
going to be from 0 to 2 pi so if we they
just asked from 0 to 2 pi these would be
your angles or if you want a general
solution this is your general solution
let's take a look at another example
now before we dive into example number
five you might be saying Mario I noticed
there's something on your shirt there
and I don't know if you can see this
here but I've got these unit circle
shirt on today just to kind of in honor
of this video and if you're interested
in getting a t-shirt like this I have
these for sale on my Teespring store and
I'll put a link in the description below
so check that out if you want to get one
of these cool fun math t-shirts but
let's try number five now so for number
five we're trying to get the secant
function by itself on one side of the
equation so instead of multiplying by
square root of 3
let's divide both sides by square root
of 3.
okay so now we have secant of x divided
by 2. now secant you know from your trig
identities is the reciprocal of cosine
so we could write this as secant as the
same as 1 over
cosine of x divided by 2.
equals 2 divided by root 3. now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to take the
reciprocal of both sides of this
equation so when I flip this over cosine
divided by 1 is just going to be cosine
so we have cosine of the angle x divided
by 2 is equal to the reciprocal of the
right side which is equal to square root
3 over 2. now like just like we did in
the last example we're going to treat
this quantity here this angle like a
group or a chunk we're going to say
cosine of what is equal to square root 3
over 2. now on the unit circle cosine is
the x coordinate right so where is the x
coordinate root 3 over 2 that's going to
be here at pi over 6 and here at 11 pi
over 6. so what I normally do is I draw
a little sketch like this on my side of
my paper I'd say right here at pi over 6
and 11 pi over 6.
now you can see these are not across
from each other so it's not like I can
do that little trick where I'm just
adding pi and and there's not like a
they're not evenly spaced I guess you
could say so what I would do to write
this as a general solution is I would
say
X over 2. remember we treated this like
a group is equal to pi over 6
plus 2 pi n meaning we're adding 360
degrees we're going all the way around
that unit circle to get back into the
same position where
the cosine is equal to three over two we
can also do the same thing with
11 pi over 6.
we can add 2 pi or multiples of 2 pi to
get back to the same spot where cosine
is equal to root three over two but keep
in mind we're not solving for x divided
by two we just want to solve for x so
we're going to do is we're going to
multiply both sides of the equation by 2
and so that's going to give us x equals
2 pi over 6 which is pi over 3
plus 4 Pi n
and
11 pi over 3
actually 22 pi over 6 but it reduces to
11 pi over 3 right plus 4 Pi n
and that's our general solution now if
it said just from 0 to 2 pi if we put 0
in for n pi over 3 would be
one of our answers or if we put 1 in
that's going to be 4 pi plus pi over 3
but you can see 4 pi plus pi over 3 is
greater than 2 pi so that's not going to
work if we put 0 here we get 11 pi over
and now 11 pi over 3 is that between 0
and 2 pi well this is actually three and
two-thirds Pi so that's not between 0
and 2 pi so really in this case there's
only one answer from 0 to 2 pi and
that's going to be when X is pi over 3.
so that's it between 0 to 2 pi and this
is your general solution and you got it
let's take a look at one more example
okay let's take a look at example number
six and if you want more practice at the
end of this video I'll have a link to
another video that I did previously
working with solving trig equations
uh but let's look for number six so
number six we have tangent squared x
minus tangent x minus two equals zero so
notice we have a trinomial three terms
and let's see if we can Factor this
trinomial into two binomials so we can
see that tangent
times tangent is going to give us
tangent squared what two numbers
multiply to negative two but add to
negative one that's going to be negative
two and positive one so you can see the
inside one tangent X and the outside
negative two tangent X adds up to our
middle term negative one tangent X now
that we have it factored let's set each
factor equal to zero and solve so we're
going to say tangent of X plus one
equals zero
and
tangent of x minus two equals zero
subtract one from both sides so you can
see tangent x equals negative one add
two to both sides you can see tangent of
X is equal to two
now on the unit circle we know where
tangent is equal to negative one that's
going to be where the y coordinate
divided by the x coordinate is equal to
negative 1. so that would occur right
here at 3 pi over 4 because you can see
that root 2 over 2 divided by negative
root 2 over 2 is negative one anything
divided by itself is one but a positive
divided by negative is a negative one
and it also occurs over here at 7 pi
over four
so let's draw a little sketch here so
basically we're looking at three pi over
4 and 7 pi over 4 and notice that
they're across from each other
on that unit circle so if we're going to
write a general solution we could say x
equals 3 pi over 4 plus
Pi n where n is an integer right so if
you keep adding Pi you're going like a
half Revolution over here though we
don't know where tangent is equal to two
so we're going to have to go to our
calculator and make sure your mode is in
radians okay I'll just check minus in
radians and I'm going to do the tangent
inverse now so I'm going to say x is
equal to the tangent inverse of 2 and on
your calculator you might have to press
your second key so second tangent
inverse of 2
I'm getting 1.11
[Music]
now the calculator is only going to give
you one answer 1.11 radians pi over 2 pi
is 3.14 divided by 2. so this is about
1.57
1.11 would be somewhere here in the
first quadrant so if we were to draw a
sketch
that's going to be somewhere right I'll
just say right about here approximately
1.11
but tangent is positive in the first
quadrant and in the third quadrant
because remember tangent is y over X and
if they're both negative a negative by
negative is a positive so what we can do
is we can take this
reference angle okay or this reference
triangle and draw that same angle with
the x-axis in the third quadrant so what
I could do is if I wanted to write this
as a general solution I could say these
are 180 degrees apart okay see how
that's like a diameter so I could say
1.11 Plus
Pi n meaning I'm just adding Pi or 3.14
to get to the next one next one you know
add infinitum so this would be your
general solution both of these but if it
said just from 0 to 2 pi you could say 3
pi over 4
and we said 7 pi over 4.
and then over here we said 1.11
and what's 1.11 plus pi
well Pi is about 3.14 so it'd be about
4.25 and those would be your answers
from 0 to 2 pi but these would be your
your general solution so great job if
you're able to follow this video in
these six examples if you want more
practice follow me over to that video
right there that I did previously
talking about how to solve trig
equations and I'll see you over in that
video